[MUSIC].
I, I'm the first speaker today, and
we're actually talking about speaking with
and acting with power.
well, you know, like, like, I like, oh.
>> [LAUGH].
>> sorry.
[LAUGH].
So today we're talking about speaking and
acting with power,
and I know that all of us deal with this
everyday, and,.
You know, it's something that sometimes we
kind of get lost and
don't know where our slides are.
My slide is here for example.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Yeah, and you know, like.
>> Stop, stop.
It doesn't work this way.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Your appearance, your gestures, and
obvious lack of preparation.
Everything plays against you.
But it's not about bow, it's all about
ugh.
Every day, we have a lot of conversations,
with our professors, with our friends,
with our classmates.
And we may easily find our self in a
situation,
when we unintentionally lose our power.
So today we would like to focus.
A communication skill that will allow you
to gain your power intentionally, and
to avoid a situation, when you lose your
power accidentally.
And these communication skills are acting
and speaking with power.
So in the first part of our presentation,
we would like to talk about acting with
power.
Doing, for example, a presentation at
work.
Then we would like to move on speaking
with power,
because sometimes there's no opportunity
to act with power.
For example, on a phone interview the only
opportunity to communicate your
power is to speak with power.
So, now let's come back to the beginning
of our presentation, and
let's look what mistakes Bahn did and how
she could do it differently.
>> Right, so obviously Bahn knows to do
this a lot better than she did today,
but, she did a few mistakes that we're
gonna go through today.
Just to give you an example of what you
can do to make it better.
So, the first seconds, how did she appear?
What is, what is the first impression you
have from your appearance?
Acting with power means appearing powerful
having status in the room and
the way she looked was just not
appropriate for this audience.
There are studies that show that when you
have a proper dress, when you have a suit,
when you have a uniform, something that
attributes status to you,
people will perceive you as powerful, and
power add into it.
The second thing that Paula did is she
didn't look very prepared.
It was very obvious that.
Note, she kind of have to look for her
notes.
She, she had to kind of cling on to the
facts that she had on the paper.
She even was pointing to us and kind of
looking for
help, and when you act with power, you're
on your own.
People will perceive you as the person who
is in charge and who knows what to do.
And you don't, don't look for excuses.
One very important thing about acting with
power is don't, don't apologize.
Don't be sorry, don't be sad.
In case of doubt, it's better to come
across as aggressive, then I'll pause,
then, then coming across as sad.
And the last point.
Is, her, her gestures, her postures.
We've heard a lot about that today, but
just a few key points.
Where did she stand in the room?
Here with her notes, she was hiding.
Where you wanna be, is, you wanna be on
the stage.
You wanna occupy the stage.
You wanna have, you, you wanna have, you
know, some presence.
And,.
It's about doing a great job and, and kind
of,
like, twisting around and showing this,
that's not what you want to be.
We want to be right here in the middle,
and you want to communicate and
establish a presence with your audience.
With that, I'll like to invite Fay and
Svetlana to the.
To the stage.
To show us another example, about how to
speak with power.
>> So, good morning Mr. Smith.
>> Good morning Svetlana.
So, Svetlana, what do you think is great
about working at.
>> Oh, yeah, you know, Before I entered
Stanford Business School,
I worked in Mackenzie and we had a great,-
>> Oh, I worked there, too, I was in the,
South Africa office.
>> Oh, this is with [UNKNOWN] so
we had a great project with Google and I
realize that this is a great company.
And, I like its corporate culture.
It promotes innovation and independent
thinking.
And I really need intellectual
flexibility.
I also like its mission.
The company's mission is about organizing
information, and
making it accessible all over the world.
And people, yeah Google hires a lot of
very smart, talented people.
It's a great pleasure to work there, and
fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I like fun.
I think, it's really funny to walk in
Google.
And oh, yeah, entrepreneurship, yeah,
entrepreneurship is also [CROSS-TALK].
>> So, so, so, so, so.
What will you say your greatest strengths
are?
>> yeah.
I think I'm a proactive person.
I always try to go beyond my direct
responsibilities, and
add value to any task that I do and exceed
the expectations.
I'm also a very supportive person, and I.
>> [CROSS-TALK] This thing is not the way
that you've learned it.
Interview.
When you do an interview,
you want to be the center of attention.
When you do an interview, you want to
speak with power, be,
if you wanna be William, who wants people
to remember where he is when you're doing
a presentation or are you Jason, who's a,
a regular speaker here at the GSB.
Or you're like J.D. who is the
inspirational teacher for all of us.
You want to speak with power.
And today I'm gonna introduce to everyone
three different ways to speak with power.
Firstly, interruptions.
What could be now a hinder, and I could
take that question.
But what is better would be for me to say,
I'll take that question later.
Let me continue with what I have to say.
The good thing about doing that is one,
that you keep your audience focused on you
and what your train of thoughts are.
Two, you, you make sure.
That you're not distracted by any
questions that come up.
And three, you maintain control, you keep
control of what the scene is like,
and where the conversation is going.
The second point, have the list of three.
Not one, not two, but three.
Now, having three clear and
concise points, help people know what they
want to take away from your talk.
Secondly, it helps you remember what you
have to say.
I remember now, that I have three
different points.
And my third point, which I haven't
covered, tells you that you want to
take away three different points today,
from our presentation.
And it makes sure that the audience keep
track.
With what [UNKNOWN] about.
The last point.
You want to have contrasting points.
Why contrasts?
What happened to Svetlana earlier on when
she said,
I'm proactive you know, usually
participate and u.
I make sure that everyone is involved,
know that, that's all of us,
I'm pretty sure given you guys are GSB
students.
But what could be better would be for you
to say, I had a colleague once who never
took the initiative but rather, I decided
I wanted to do this or that instead.
Hence, what could have been a really good
interview for
Svetlana, was ruined because she allowed
interruptions.
Because she did not have three clear and
concise points, and she did not use the
power of contrast.
Now what could be for everyone here is for
you to take control.
For you to be clear and concise in your
points.
And finally, to use the power of contrast
that you all the better speakers.
And the powerful speakers that we all aim
to be.
I will now pass on to Faith, to give you a
clear and
concise, concrete action to take to reach
this goal.
>> So we have seen how not to act and
speak with power, and
we have told you how to act and speak with
power.
But why does this matter to you?
The answer lies in each and every one of
your calendars.
You have job interviews.
You have presentations, and you have
networking events.
Acting and speaking with power at a job
interview will allow you
to communicate your expertise and core
competencies excellently.
Landing you that dream job.
[UNKNOWN] presentation, acting and
speaking with power
will allow you to be more persuasive,
really driving home those final points.
And at networking events, imagine.
You're in a room full of hundreds of
people, every one looking to stand out.
But, how do you do that?
The best way is to use acting and speaking
with power to
separate yourself, making you stand out
from the crowd.
Turning, turning yourself from one of
those people who are looking for
other people to, to potentially notice
them.
To that person, who has everyone
gravitating towards them.
So, what's the take away for you today?
We have created what we have aptly named a
day-to-day guide to power.
It is a list of items, you can use every
single day
to make you a person, who more frequently
acts and speaks with power.
By going through this guide, within a
week, maybe two,
you will be seen and perceived by your
peers and
friends to be a much more powerful
speaker, with the goal that you are.
Better at in-,
At interviewing.
Better at presenting.
And also, better at networking, as well.
Making you the perfectly most well-rounded
professional you could ever possibly be.
[MUSIC].